[MUSIC PLAYING] AMAH EDOH: The point is that
these events-- they didn't end in the past.
The issue is that these events that happened
centuries ago, decades ago, continue to live
on today.
Their impacts continue to be felt.
SARAH HANSEN: Today on Chalk Radio, we're
exploring transitional and reparative justice,
and how seeking expertise from everywhere
might lead to better understanding.
AMAH EDOH: The process of reparative justice
is about how do we address that.
How do we address what is today?
And how do we seek justice for what's happened
in the past as a means towards addressing
these challenges today, and being able to
move forward from them, being able to move
on to something else?
SARAH HANSEN: I'm your host, Sarah Hansen.
My guest today is Professor Amah Edoh, an
Assistant Professor of Anthropology and African
Studies at MIT.
You may remember Amah from her episode on
Chalk Radio back in season one.
We're sitting down with her again, this time
to discuss her course called "Reparations
for Slavery and Colonization, Contemporary
Movements for Justice."
The inspiration for the course came in part
from the Black Lives Matter protests that
took place around the world in 2020.
AMAH EDOH: What was expressed during these
protests, whether in the US or in Europe--
where I have a lot of friends and collaborators,
and so I was hearing echoes from both sides
of the Atlantic-- was kind of a framing of
contemporary racial injustice, racial discrimination,
racism, as a legacy of slavery and colonialism.
And so thinking about police violence, but
also thinking about housing discrimination,
and also thinking about the collections that
are held in European or American museums,
thinking about so many aspects of our lives
today, and recognizing that so many of the
disparities and the injustices that were brought
to the surface through these protests, and
that we're surrounded by at all times, have
a historical origin.
This is what was so powerful in these protests
around the world, was that they were saying
there's no dealing with what we recognize
as a problem today without dealing or talking
about what happened in the past.
And so this class was meant to take that seriously,
and to say, what are the models for that?
Because reparations has been, and continues
to be, an incendiary topic, or still seen
as somewhat controversial.
And I think part of that stems from partial
understanding about what is meant by reparations,
and it's kind of a knee-jerk reaction to the
idea of what reparations is.
SARAH HANSEN: If you've been on any social
media site recently, Amah's statement likely
feels true to you.
There do seem to be strong reactions to the
idea of what reparations are.
I asked Amah how she defines or conceptualize
reparations.
AMAH EDOH: It's about establishing the record,
the historical record, or redressing the historical
record so that the harms that have been done
can be named, and then thinking about, what
might justice look like.
It's one thing to learn from events that have
happened in the past.
It's another to try to learn from what's happening
in the moment, and put that in conversation,
of course, with what's happened in the past,
but to document, learn, and interrogate what's
happening as it's happening was super exciting.
And the prospect of engaging students in that
process, to me, was really, really powerful
as an instructor.
SARAH HANSEN: Amah's interest in justice and
anthropology is something that stems from
her past.
She shared how growing up across Western and
Southern Africa, and the United States, shaped
her understanding of what it means to be Black
and African in the world.
AMAH EDOH: So I was born in the US.
My parents were in graduate school in the
US from Togo.
And so I had an American passport from birth.
And I was the only one in my family to have
an American passport, and among my friends
who were in Togo.
And I remember as young as, I don't know,
five or six, feeling that having this American
passport was really special, and that somehow
it made me "better."
It doesn't feel great to admit that, but that's
the truth of it.
I felt somehow special because I had this
American passport.
Why does a six-year-old have that kind of
consciousness?
Where does that come from?
There was always a sense that real life happened
elsewhere, that real life was happening in
the US, real life was happening in Europe
and all these other places.
And the goal and the idea was always to leave.
And then race comes into it, when I started
paying attention to skin bleaching or even
just hair straightening.
These were things that I was noticing in my
environment.
Whether in Togo, it was Congolese music videos.
We listened to a lot of music from the Congo
at the time.
And so I started noticing, or there was a
moment where you'd start noticing, men and
women who bleach their skin.
And so you could see the signs.
And then this question about why?
Why is that a thing?
And after college, I was in Zambia for a few years and...
I remember one day, I tried to actually make
an experiment of it.
And I was on the minibus, and I was looking
out the window.
And I was, like, let me count how many women
that I see actually skin bleached, or who
have evidence of skin bleaching.
And it was three out of four just doing this
little ride.
So this question about what does lighter skin
mean, why do people put themselves through
this, given the health effects, and so on?
Questions about skin color, about race, about
one's place in the world-- all of these things
are part of, for me, the question of Africanness
in the world.
SARAH HANSEN: Amah understands that students,
too, bring their personal histories into the
classroom.
She tries to create a space for sharing perspectives
and honoring individual experiences.
And when discussing concepts like reparations,
it becomes all the more important to do this.
AMAH EDOH: I think it's really about opening
up space for sharing, for conversation, and
honoring all the participants' contributions,
and showing that we're building this thing
together as we go and learning together.
One thing that's evolved for me over the course
of the semester, even, was just trying to
shift from talking about reparations to talking
about reparative justice.
I think there are associations that are made
with the word "reparations," and that can
prompt knee-jerk reactions.
I think that emphasizing the justice side
of it and the perceptual side of it, by saying
"reparative justice," opens up a little bit
of space.
But reparations or reparative justice, I think,
can be or should be part of a transitional
justice mechanism, which is really just meant
to address widespread or large-scale human
rights violations.
Reparative justice might be one of the many
things that go into seeking justice for abuses
of violations that happen on a large scale,
where you can't deal with the harms that were
done to people individually.
SARAH HANSEN: While material compensation
is one of the most common examples of reparations,
Amah explained that reparative justice isn't
just limited to that.
Things such as amending our historical records,
and honoring the people who've been disenfranchised
by colonization and racial inequity, are just
as important.
AMAH EDOH: You can have material reparations
in the form of money or land or other forms
of resources, and then also symbolic reparations
that are, ideally, part of a healing process,
a process of acknowledging that these harms
were made, that they had significant impacts,
and that moving forward requires actually
addressing what's happened in the past.
Because oftentimes, this is a critique that's
brought forward-- why do you want to reopen
old wounds?
This is just going to stoke tension.
It's going to stoke conflict.
This is only just-- it happened a long time
ago.
People today are not responsible for what
was done centuries ago, et cetera, et cetera.
But the point is that these events didn't
end in the past.
The issue is that these events that happened
centuries ago, decades ago, continue to live
on today.
Their impacts continue to be felt whether,
it's at the level of individual bodies, or
if it's at the level of societies, or in the
landscape, in the literal land.
The legacies of colonialism in various parts
of the world is held in the actual land, are
held in people's bodies physically, psychologically,
not to mention the structural disadvantage
that the descendants of enslaved people or
formerly colonized people continue to face.
So these issues are not past.
There's nothing that's past about them.
They're very much in the present tense.
And so the process of reparative justice is
about how do we address that.
How do we address what is today, and how do
we seek justice for what's happened in the
past as a means towards addressing these challenges
today, and being able to move forward from
them, being able to move on to something else?
That's where the transitional justice angle,
or frame comes in, or the language, let's
say.
Like if we think about this as a transition
towards something better, reparative justice
needs to be part of that.
SARAH HANSEN: One of the main assignment students
work on in the course is creating a case study
documenting what it takes to work towards
reparative justice and what challenges, arise
along the way.
By compiling these studies, Amah is building
up an archive within her lab, the African
Futures Action Lab, which she co-founded with
her colleague, Liliane Umubyeyi.
The goal of the Lab is to support unfolding
movements for reparative justice across Europe,
Africa, and the Americas.
Amah's course seeks to combine the expertise
of different activist groups, one from Algeria
and one in Belgium, with those of guest speakers
by bringing them together for discussions.
These dialogues are shared in the classroom,
where students can discuss them and apply
them to their case studies.
AMAH EDOH: Essentially, the model for the
class comes from the AFA Lab, the African
Futures Action Lab, what's at the core of
our mission, which is to bring together different
or to connect different forms of expertise
around these questions, recognizing that you
have all these people who hold a lot of knowledge
and expertise relevant to these struggles
for justice, and for racial justice, and reparative
justice, but who are not necessarily in conversations
one another.
So how do we facilitate these exchanges?
And so bringing that in conversation with
the classroom, and saying, how can we not
only bring these different folks in conversation
with one another, but how can we have that
be part of the learning experience for students?
In the case of the Algeria group, it was made
up of three scholars and activists who are
Algerian.
They approached us because they were interested
in exploring what had been done, the kinds
of claims that had been brought against the
French state for colonial violence broadly,
and then specifically also for nuclear tests
that were conducted in Algeria in the Sahara
after independence.
The second group was already organized as
a civil society organization, so it was a
collective of Afro-descendant Belgian people
that was formed in response to a commission
that was set up by the Belgian state this
summer to examine Belgium's colonial past
in the Congo, Burundi, and Rwanda.
One of the speakers that we brought in was
Anna Moyo-Kupeta, who is the Executive Director
of the Center for the Study of Violence and
Reconciliation in South Africa.
And she's a transitional justice expert, and
a lawyer, and long-time activist.
She came in to speak with the Belgian group,
in particular, about how civil society can
hold accountable the state commission, the
role that civil society can play in transitional
justice processes.
And it was a super interesting conversation,
a bit intimidating, I think, in the sense
that she really laid out to us how this is
work that unfolds over the course of years,
like the lobbying, and the advocacy work,
and the sentinel work that civil society organizations
have to do to hold state entities accountable.
And so it made it really concrete for the
group who could then say, what are we able
to do given the time and the resources that
we have?
It was really important for us to have, throughout
this process, to have voices that are coming
from different directions.
So to have an expert from South Africa inform
the process in Belgium, for instance, was
really important to us.
Because again, we think about the many layers
of intervention that this course, or the work
that we're doing with the Lab, is meant to
do, to accomplish.
It's also to highlight the fact that expertise
resides everywhere.
And it's not just a North-South direction
for the transfer of knowledge information,
but South-South, South-North, all of it.
SARAH HANSEN: Expertise resides everywhere.
That's a powerful idea.
And it's one that shaped how Amah designed
the course.
As part of the course, she shared guest speakers'
videos on the MIT OpenCourseWare YouTube channel.
She invited learners from around the world
to share their expertise, questions, and perspectives
in the comments.
AMAH EDOH: The idea was that these comments
could then be brought back into the classroom,
and then we could, in the classroom, engage
them and be in conversation with those comments.
And then that I could then bring it back.
How did it actually unfold?
There were a lot of comments that felt like
knee-jerk reactions to "reparations" being
in the title rather than the actual content
of the videos.
That was different from what we had envisioned.
And so I think we had less material to work
with in terms of the comments of the videos
that could be brought into the classroom than
what we had imagined.
But still, it was very interesting and generative
to bring back the comments that we did get
into the classroom.
We had some really nice discussions with students.
Because it reminded us again that these issues
that we're dealing with in the class are unfolding
live.
SARAH HANSEN: Amah later explained to me that
in hindsight, it might have been helpful to
provide more connective tissue for the YouTube
audience.
After all, students attending the MIT class
had access to readings and other course materials
to provide context, and to frame the discussion
around reparations.
YouTube learners didn't have those materials.
To fix that, Amah is currently working on
sharing all of her teaching materials from
the course on our MIT OpenCourseWare website.
I found Amah's reflections interesting, so
I asked her to share three tips for other
educators who might want to try opening their
classrooms through public forums.
AMAH EDOH: I think having some degree of awareness
of how your topic is seen, or will land, or
what it means out in the world, but remembering
what does this mean to people outside of that
setting, because that has implications for
the kinds of comments that you might get,
and therefore, how you might frame-- how you
share what you share, how you respond, and
so on.
Having a great team-- I think it's absolutely
a team effort.
I think working with folks who are-- again,
back to the question of expertise-- who are
coming in with knowledge that we can't have
all the knowledge in ourselves.
So you all brought in knowledge about these
educational platforms that open up onto the
world and what it takes to make that possible
technically.
And also, in terms of the nature of the engagement,
what we can expect, how to plan for that,
all that and all of it, really having to be
a team effort.
And taking stock ahead of time of the range
of expertise that's needed to do this, both
technically, content-wise, and conceptually.
And then the third tip, I think, is not to
be afraid to experiment.
I think a few months ago, we're just, like,
oh, god, how is this going to work out?
We had the sense-- I think we all felt that
this was a good idea, and I still think it's
a good idea.
And I really hope to see it in the full-blown
version of the vision.
Because I really still believe in the idea.
I still believe in the model.
I'm grateful to you all for your willingness,
also, to experiment.
And I think that that's something that we
were all, let's just try it.
Let's just try it and let's see what works.
And I think we really did manage to-- nothing
went massively wrong.
And actually, I think some things actually
went-- a lot actually went right.
And I certainly learned a lot from it.
And seeing what my students produced at the
end of it, I think they got a lot from it.
Activists at the end were very grateful and
also inspired by the process.
So I think it was a success in many ways.
So I think being willing to take risks, and
to experiment, and to recognize that it's
not going to be perfect at the first pass--
this is part of learning.
It's about making mistakes and figuring it
out as you go, so you can do it better next
time.
SARAH HANSEN: This is a philosophy that Amah
is truly living out.
She shared some things she hopes to learn
from other educators to improve how teaching
and learning unfold in her classroom.
AMAH EDOH: I would love to learn more about
how folks talk about a topic that's considered
controversial, incendiary, in a way that draws
people in-- that both does justice to the
seriousness of it and that's uncompromising
in terms of its sense of what needs to be
done and the importance of it, without being
alienating.
How do you draw folks in without compromising
on the reality or your sense of why this matters
and what it is?
How do you draw people in without compromising
on that?
And then, relatedly, we can't underestimate
the challenges of talking or interacting across
areas of practice and disciplines and expertise.
We don't speak the same language.
We don't think in the same terms.
And so how folks have navigated that, because
building relationships takes time.
So how do you foster space where folks can
interact meaningfully when they don't have
very much time to spend together?
SARAH HANSEN: This idea of bringing people
from different practices and disciplines together
to find expertise everywhere is part of what
makes Professor Edoh's course so valuable.
It creates a wealth of perspectives that are
actively reshaping how we view the conversation
on race, justice, and equity around the globe.
If you're interested in adding your expertise,
or to learn from others, you can find Amah's
videos on our MIT OpenCourseWare YouTube site.
You'll soon find her teaching materials on
our MIT OpenCourseWare website, as well.
You can find Amah's lab online at www.africanfutures.mit.edu.
Thank you so much for listening.
Until next time, signing off from Cambridge,
Massachusetts, I'm your host, Sarah Hansen
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
Chalk Radio's producers include myself, Brett
Paci, and Dave Lishansky.
Our scriptwriters are Nidhi Shastri and Aubrey
Calaway.
Show notes for this episode were written by
Peter Chipman.
And Amah Edoh's course materials are shared
on our OCW website by Reese Jenkins.
We're funded by MIT Open Learning and supporters
like you.